yo let me uh because so you're a white
man who's with a Puerto Rican language
I'm a biological white male yes so am I
talked I don't know I have a lot of
people who I can relate to go into the
Latin the Latino my wife's side of the
family's yes family events parties and
being the only white guy there yes and
like you're kind of like Kevin yeah it's
it's here's the thing it's one of those
things where you know a lot of times the
family speaking Spanish most of the time
including my seven-year-old daughter
we'll just start talking to me sometimes
in Spanish and I'm like did you just
have a stroke I don't know what you're
saying at all
um and and uh and you know getting used
to the culture and the food
um you know the first time
the first time I ever had uh um paella
um uh yes and yeah that and and um and
uh what's uh Bernie the the the pork
that was I mean I loved it delicious but
I genuinely [ __ ] blood and because my
Germanic GI system was like what did you
just do did you just we've never seen
this we can't process it we need to
bleed what is this we need to bleed but
it's the food is so good that you just
go back for more and I gotta be honest
man I've loved the Latino culture so
much always happy yeah you know always
vibrant dancing you know best food hard
food tits I love it yeah you know uh
everybody you know the the most
beautiful women in the world to me are
like literally I would say the most
beautiful women and men my girls family
are just the hottest people
either gender I've ever they even have
hot pets I'm like dude I want to [ __ ]
your dog